okay so last time we did a lot of
algebraic work to establish this
relationship between the semi-major axis
of semi minor axis and the eccentricity
of the ellipse okay so before we do a
bit more exploration and investigation
about what this relationship reveals
first let's just do some sort of
low-grade mechanical type stuff stuff
that we can work out based on this so if
we have an equation of an ellipse okay
we can use this formula to work out
where all the important features are the
focus foci the directrix the director
sees and by extension the eccentricity
okay so how do we do it well have a look
at this you can see this is the larger
length here so this is going to be the
semi-major axis Square okay this is
going to be the same minor axis squared
so now we have these two pieces which
are going to fit into here which as you
can see once you solve this you'll have
a value for e okay so let's just quickly
do that you've got 5 equal to 9 minus 9
times 1 minus B squared so shift things
around a little bit you have 5 over 9 1
minus B squared subtract one from both
sides or maybe rather add a square to
this side and subtract 5 or 9 from this
side 9 and now you can take the square
root now we are only going to take just
the one value the positive one because
remember what X interesting is it's a
ratio okay so therefore it's positive ok
so there you go that's eccentricities
now how do I use this to work out where
the focus foci and directrix director
sees ah well remember that we establish
that the focus was at plus or minus AE
comma zero okay so it's at zero because
what you've got is an ellipse centered
on the origin
so that's why you're right on the axis
okay now it's plus or minus because of
the symmetry you've got both sides there
so you're going to have two foci now a
in this case since that's a square that
implies that a is three and that's what
I'm gonna need along with the xmas
tricity to work over the focus of that
folk my arm
okay so here you're gonna say plus or
minus three times a that's just two so
there are the two foci okay
in exactly the same way I can work out
where the director sees are they're
going to be x equals plus or minus again
because there are two of them a over a
and that'll tell you where how far
across you are so plus or minus three
over two over three which gives you 9
over 2 which is 4 and are hot okay now
just before we move off this suppose
I've shifted it around a little bit
let's take this ellipse let's consider
what happens if I change the values so
if I go x squared on 5 y squared or not
okay what's going to happen there well
because now there's semi-major in the
same minor axis I'm not a range they
were the way they were before this now
is the semi-minor axis the horizontal
one that's B squared this is the
semi-major axis which is vertical so
instead of being this thing would be
flatter like so okay this thing is going
to be thinner like this okay now since
therefore we're thinking about the axis
semi-major axis and say minor axis being
swapped around everything else is also
spots around so the foci are no longer
on the x values being both sides they're
on the Y values okay so you're going to
have the foci being at 0 plus or minus 2
in this case cuz I'm just taking the
same
in the same way the director sees are
going to be these horizontal lines over
here which gives you y equals plus or
minus foreign car the same values it's
just one instead of X this is just a
mountain so that's how you can take a
standard form equation ellipse use this
relationship be spayed a squared 1 minus
e squared and get out the main features
focus directrix and so on now all that's
pretty pedestrian to be honest okay we
want to do some investigation okay so
some of the questions in the textbook
they'll set things like examine the
behavior or consider what happens with
right so I wants to think about this B
squared a squared in particular as the
eccentricity changes that seems to be
the most useful fascinating thing it
gives us whole different shapes what
happens as it changes okay so what
things do we already know well if I
consider e equals 1 equals 1 well what
happens to this equation right that
creates this effect B squared equals a
squared times 1 minus 1 was equal to 0
now what does that mean okay well a semi
a semi minor axis of nothing the reason
why this is a problem is because what is
eccentricity 1 okay X interesting one is
a parabola okay so it doesn't have semi
major axis or semi minor axis the way an
ellipse does okay all right that's fine
well let's consider then what happens as
we reduce the value okay now we already
have seen I think the very first ellipse
you considered how to make centricity of
1/2 this ellipse is an eccentricity of
two-thirds so we've got all these
fractional values what happens as a
approaches 0 as it gets smaller and
smaller and smaller now
we're gonna write this out with some
proper language okay so I'm gonna take
the limit as a approaches 0 of B squared
okay now I want to try to examine
like here what happens to the semi-minor
axes well the limit of this is a
producer is going to limit of this as a
producer because it the same right so
you've got the limit as a approaches
Europe off a squibbitt
one minus V squared okay so what happens
to you well because unlike when we were
doing this with first principles this
limit I can actually just evaluate it at
0 right I can say that's going to be a
square times 1 minus 0 a square times 1
what does this tell us
as a approaches 0 B squared is going to
be a square when you get there if it
were possible okay
well what kind of scenario is this well
if we for instance have a look at it is
B squared approaching a square what kind
of shape would you get this is our
example here you'd have x squared on 9
and you got B squared which in that case
was fine but if that's approaching the
night as well what kind of shape is this
the answer is if you multiply through at
least in this case it's a circle set of
the origin hmm so stop for a second just
take take mental stock taker what's
going on as he approaches zero as a
register register reduces it doesn't
make much sense to say e equals zero
because he's ratio what does it mean for
something to be in the ratio zero that
doesn't really compute but as you
approach there you're getting something
like a circle okay now this is starting
to dig at the very idea or the very very
reason rather of why you know e means
we've given it the name eccentricity
okay you can tell it's it's the same as
the word eccentric just you know
adjectives or nouns
what does eccentric mean when you talk
about someone who is eccentric their
personalities eccentric
what we tend to mean is it's kind of
like you know you've got a group of
people normal group of people
and then you've got a guy who's sort of
different from the rest of us okay it's
sort of all sent up okay that's what we
mean by eccentric you can take a word
like constant you can see how it it
means something quite different it means
that you've got some people some things
which are the same sent on okay that's
what concentric circles are yeah
so therefore what does eccentricity mean
in the context of these shapes right
when eccentricity is zero if such a
thing were possible they get a cycle as
you increase the eccentricity you get
something which is circular but it's not
a circle anymore okay it's gonna become
stretched out or squashed those kinds of
things as the eccentricities increases
even further you don't even have a shape
which is closed anymore it sort of
breaks open okay when the x intercept is
equal to one which then begs the
question well what happens when the
interest eccentricity goes further okay
well that's what we're going to have a
look at next time the kind of shape that
we get some of you may already know what
the shape that emerges out of this is
but the real question is why is it that
shape what does it have to do with the
whole name of this topic which is you
know conic sections okay what
relationship to all of these pieces have
together that's all we're gonna explore
next